The first one be five times the square root of x, and the second one be
thirteen times the forth root of five. Nice thinking if you got those two
correct. The key to understanding these problems is that we can only add the
radicals if the radicands are the same and if the indexes are the same. Here we
have square roots and both of the roots have a radicand of x. So we have three
square roots of x, and two square roots of x. So all together, we'll have five
square roots of x. We're simply combining like terms just as we would with
polynomials or with fractions. Here we combined the x squareds, and here we
added together sevenths. So in the second example, we're really adding six
fourth roots of 5, and seven four roots of five. So all together, we'll have 13
fourth roots of 5. The type of radical doesn't change in each case. We still
have the square root of x in the first one and the 4 through the 5 in the
second one.